foreign
[Music]
this is Sky News at 10 our top story
is this the end Mr Johnson
have you run out of Road
the former prime minister accused of
deliberately and repeatedly misleading
Parliament over party gate
Boris Johnson branded the reports of
political assassination as a date is
confirmed for the by-election to replace
him also tonight
[Music]
hold no hate the message to thousands
after victims families observe a minute
silence in Nottingham
at least 40 children among hundreds
feared dead after an overcrowded fishing
boat capsized with the Greek Coast Guard
close by
our Net Zero targets are creating a
winter energy gap with coal power no
longer a viable option plus
any Queen who could be gulled by such a
pretty wicked fellow and take him to her
bed and put a crown up on his head does
not Inspire fear she inspires pity
from Hollywood to Westminster tributes
to oscar-winning actress turned labor MP
Glenda Jackson who's died aged 87.
and we'll take a first look
first look just that's in the Press
preview from 10 30.
[Music]
hello very very good evening he has
become the figurehead of the
conservative Civil War today a
parliamentary inquiry concluded Boris
Johnson deliberately misled Parliament
over partygate again and again the
scathing report from the Privileges
committee found that Downing Street
staff regularly broke covid rules and
engaged in a pantomime to stop their
behavior becoming public but the former
prime minister described the findings as
deranged and lies and we're the divisive
Commons vote next week in a tricky
by-election in his former constituency
next month his disruptive influence will
continue to Rattle the government Skies
political editor Beth Rigby reports
is this the end Mr Johnson
once
upster now out of office out of
Parliament and for now out of political
Road
after a 14-month investigation finally
time for the verdict did Boris Johnson
mislead Parliament over partygate a
unanimous yes from the Privileges
committee its report damning of Boris
Johnson's conduct and character
accusing him of having deliberately
misled the House of Commons and the
committee investigating him
impugning their work undermining the
Democratic process while being complicit
in the campaign of abuse and attempted
intimidation of the committee
enough to recommend a suspension of 90
days if he was still an MP far exceeding
the period needed to trigger a
by-election and a recommendation that
his parliamentary members pass be
withdrawn
Boris Johnson he's not only a law
breaker but a layer he's not fit for
public office and he's disgraced himself
and continues to act like a you know
pound shot Trump in the way in which he
tries to discredit anybody who
criticizes his actions when actually a
decent public servant would have done
the honorable thing would have had a
little bit of humility and would have
apologized an apology the last thing on
Mr Johnson's mind instead pure anger the
committee now says that I deliberately
misled the house and at the moment I
spoke I was consciously concealing from
the house my knowledge of illicit events
this is rubbish it is a lie he went on
to say this report is a charade I was
wrong to believe in the committee or its
good faith the terrible truth is that it
is not I who has trusted the truth to
suit my purposes it is Harriet Harman
and her committee this is a dreadful day
for MP fees and for democracy MPS in
here agreeing with him but for very
different reasons Boris Johnson lied
he lied to MPS he lied to the people of
this country he lied to nurses doctors
care workers bus drivers everyone MPS
will vote on Monday to pass their
judgment the leader of the House clear
members will decide free from party
pressure it will be a painful process
and a sad process for all of us the task
that we we face on Monday but all of us
must do what we think is right and
others must leave us alone to do so you
have the whole of the opposition against
him but you also have the Boris haters
and the conservative party this one of
Boris Johnson's biggest allies confident
he'll lose the vote but also sure this
is not the end is he too damaged from
this can he combat will he combat it
depends on the Judgment people come to I
think many people will look at 90 days
and will think that that is simply too
harsh too aggressive and shows what the
committee was really trying to do I
think this will generate simply see for
him but he is still a popular National
figure he still has a connection with
voters that most politicians would give
their eye teeth for this PM struggling
in the polls and struggling with his
former boss on an immigration visit this
morning far away from Westminster but
not the drama engulfing his party and
what a drama it's been three separate
party gate investigations that resulted
in police fines the resignation of Boris
Johnson as pm and now his departure as
an MP it has been a Psycho Drama that
has distracted and disrupted the
conservative party and the government
and while the report is now concluded
the investigations Are Over The Fallout
continues with a party now divided by
elections on the way and a frenzy around
what Boris Johnson might do next
Boris Johnson dominated here after his
2019 Triumph now ejected from Parliament
disgraced he nevertheless looms large
keeping his options open and casting a
shadow over his successors still Beth
Rigby Sky News in Westminster
Beth would be there well it took 14
months to complete and in the end ran to
108 pages and 30 000 words it's
conclusion and recommended Essentia
tougher even than Boris Johnson's
harshest critics had expected our Deputy
political editor Sam Coates has been
pouring through the committee's findings
again and again Boris Johnson told the
public and Parliament that in here they
followed the rules
but his investigators were told by a
number 10 Insider just how untrue that
was parties and end-of-week Gatherings
all continued as normal this was all
part of a wider culture of not adhering
to any rules number 10 was like an
island oasis of normality damning
testimony about the culture inside Boris
Johnson's Downing Street revealed by a
junior number 10 official blowing the
whistle to this committee they said that
even though they set the rules for the
rest of the country they were slow to be
enforced inside number 10 the only nod
to the rules was a warning to be mindful
of the cameras on the way out it was all
they said a pantomime this the most
notorious example of that culture Boris
Johnson in November 2020 during a
lockdown surrounded by alcohol the
committee not buying his explanation
even now after the publication of this
report Boris Johnson maintains that he
had to go to leaving dues in number 10
to boost morale but the committee
disagrees they say that the coveted
rules and guidance at the time did not
allow a socially and distance event to
proceed purely for the purposes of
maintaining staff morale and this would
have been clear to Mr Johnson
it was a pattern of behavior the report
says the then prime minister standing in
the Commons making statements he must
have known were false all guidance was
followed completely during number 10
whatever happened the guidance was
followed and the rules were followed at
all times I believe that the events in
question were within the guidance and
were within the rules I came to this
house and said in all sincerity that the
rules and guidance would be followed at
all times that was four of the eight
times the committee thought that Boris
Johnson had misled Parliament and after
trawling through mountains of evidence
this is the Crux of the argument that
they reached at the end they say they
found it highly unlikely that the former
prime minister could have believed the
assertions he made to the Commons at the
time that he was making them many
aspects of Mr Johnson's defense are not
credible taken together they form
sufficient basis for a conclusion that
he intended to mislead deliberate
deception combined with a campaign of
intimidation against the committee
leaving this former prime minister
facing an unprecedented punishment Sam
coat Sky News
let's head to Westminster join our
political editor Beth root be so Beth a
vote in the Commons next week a
by-election next month Boris Johnson's
influence will be felt but can he still
make a political comeback do you think
well Jonathan I think the first thing to
say is this is certainly the closing act
on a drama that began back with brexit
in 2019 that saw Boris Johnson win the
conservative leadership to go on and win
that landslide in the 2019 election and
then him become unstuck ending uh
tonight with him out of Parliament and
really heavily sanctioned by fellow MPS
I think the big question is is this
genuinely the final act or is there
another Sequel and I have to say the
jury is out when you listen to what
Boris Johnson himself has said he said
it's farewell to Parliament for now a
very close Ally of his tonight said to
me about the vote on Monday that the
vote to remove his parliamentary pass
would be white if he was
re-elected that to me quite a bullish
statement of this being a politic
Edition that might fancy another Tilt at
that place when some time has passed I
think in the short term the vote on
Monday will be a litmus test on Boris
Johnson you might remember that back in
October last year he was planning
potentially another Tilt at the
leadership he said he had up to 100 MPS
backing him but made way for Rishi sunak
when he realized that there was a huge
chunk of the Parliamentary party that
simply wouldn't tolerate his return how
much of that base does he still retain
even his most Ardent supporters telling
me tonight they think most MPS will
abstain but if you're politically Boris
Johnson you don't want to feel your
balloon has entirely deflated he's wants
to see a show of strength in the Commons
I think for him on Monday and I think it
will give us a sense of the momentum or
not behind Boris Johnson but I think
that even though he he has left this
place he still isn't going anywhere as
you said we've got the by-elections but
beyond that will he be throwing rocks in
from the sidelines criticizing Rishi
sunax government and policy saying that
he is not honoring the manifesto on
which Boris Johnson won that huge
majority will he spend some time
building his base back with the
Grassroots I think the big picture here
is that Parliament has decided uh the
fate of Boris Johnson for now but this
is a politician that has always gone to
the public and the big question here is
what do the Grassroots of the
conservative party think what will the
public make of this over time and does
he still have the appetite to combat the
voters on Monday it's his 59th birthday
he's still a young man he still has
political ambition and the big question
and the big unknown is Will Boris
Johnson try and can he come back
okay Beth for now many thanks
hold no hate the message today from the
mother of Barnaby Weber as new details
emerged about the man suspected of
killing him and two others in Nottingham
detectives have been given a further 36
hours to question the 31 year old
suspect who is a former Nottingham
University student Katarina vitotsi
reports
[Music]
a city in shock
and United in grief
today Nottingham Stood Still
some silent
many crying
here alongside three families now
devastated after Tuesday's attacks it
feels like he's touched a lot of Hearts
over the years more than what we assumed
and knew that he had we stand here and
we feel your love and we are united in
grief and shock and disbelief
and one day we will smile again but it
will take time it just is truly so
unfair be kind to each other look after
each other don't have Hate in Your
Hearts
say prayers for my baby girl today
Nottinghamshire police revealed that the
31 year old suspect is a former student
at the University of Nottingham it's the
same University where Grace O'Malley
Kumar and Barnaby Weber had just
finished their first year of study now
please don't believe that link is a
motive in these attacks and they say
they're keeping an open mind as to what
the motive could be but there is now a
detailed timeline of what happened
please say the attack on Grace and
Barnaby happened here just after 4am
they believe the suspect then walked to
and tried to enter a supported living
complex at the time police weren't
called
in coates's body the 65 year old
caretaker was found nearby police say
the suspect stole his van and used it to
hit another man here and attempted to
run over two others at this location
police Say by this point A Marked police
car was in Pursuit
at 5 30 a.m 90 minutes after the first
attack police detain The Suspect with a
taser after the vehicle had stopped
today friends of Ian Coates shared their
memories of him with us the school
caretaker was a lifelong Keen angler who
helped troubled kids like Ben Dutton
when he was 13 by introducing him to the
sport that he loved
he set up a fishing club and we all used
to do it after school and he taught us
the basics in the classroom an
unselfless man literally just gave
everything
to them kids so that they had a chance
to do something or just add a little bit
of something in their lives and that was
Ian all over today as police confirmed
they've asked for extra time to question
the suspect more flowers arrived to
remember the victims
some left by strangers
others by those close and heartbroken by
what happened here
Catherine evertotsi Sky News Nottingham
to Greece now where three days of
mourning have been declared as fears
grow that hundreds of migrants including
children have drowned in an overcrowded
fishing boat while trying to reach
Europe the ship carrying the migrants
reportedly set off from the Libyan Port
City of to Brook around five days ago
apparently aiming to reach Italy at 11
A.M Greek time on June the 13th
authorities were told a large boat
carrying around 750 migrants was
traveling in international waters first
contact with the ship is made around
three hours later but the ship's crew
said they didn't need help the Greek
Coast Guard then shadowed The Vessel
throughout the day someone from the boat
contacted the nautical distress hotline
that evening and provided the ship's
coordinates shortly after that another
distress call from the boat this time
the caller said the vessel was moving
from side to side the Greek Coast Guard
continued to observe the ship into the
night but in the early hours of
yesterday morning it sank our Middle
East correspondent alistabunkel reports
from Kalamata where the survivors were
brought to shore
the search operation is continuing but
the weather is turning and storms are
forecast
the ship that brought the dead ashore is
back in Port and the survivors are being
looked after in a nearby Warehouse
all of them so far are men aged between
15 and 45.
no one is sure exactly how many people
are on board
everyone knows though it was a lot these
people said about
700.75
700 and 75 years but I think is
is about this small for this number I
think it's a 500
in this bottle of 550.
some of the survivors are being treated
in a local hospital and there is now
confirmation that women and children
were on board
all the women are dead says this
Survivor the women and children are dead
because they were sleeping in one room
they were staying in the room so it's
impossible that they didn't drown
relatives of the missing have come to
Greece to try and find their loved ones
aftab Khan is from the UK his cousins
were traveling from Pakistan you're
searching for your relatives
how many roses are you missing there's
three rotors and we found one relative
and is alive and we're not sure where
there's still more and
um how are they connected to you
cousins there are questions why the
Greek Coast Guard didn't intervene when
they first realized that the boat was
carrying migrants and dangerously
overcrowded they say that the boat was
in international waters and that they
were operating to International laws
it's getting close to 48 hours since the
Shipwreck and no new survivors have been
found add to that the fact that it
capsized and sank in one of the deepest
parts of the Mediterranean Sea and we
might never know how many people lost
their lives on Tuesday night
nevertheless the search goes on and
Greece is in a three-day period of
national mourning for the victims
for all the calls to prevent a repeat
disaster there will be more this summer
almost certainly
Alistair bunker Sky News in Kalamata in
southern Greece
it's one of the challenges of trying to
reach Net Zero how do you keep the
lights on during a cold still winter
when the UK's coal plants are being
mothballed well today the National Grid
insisted it was in talks to extend the
life of two coal units to provide
emergency power later this year but one
Industry Source has told Sky News that's
unlikely to happen as our climate change
correspondent Hannah Thomas Peter
reports coal-fired power stations
polluting relics of the UK's industrial
past
these days they generate a tiny
percentage of the country's electricity
but the National Grid which is charged
with keeping the lights on likes to have
some on standby to help prevent
blackouts when it's very cold and wind
power generation is low we've been
looking at the risks associated with
Russia's continued invasion of Ukraine
one of the things that the secretary of
state has asked us to do is to talk to
the coal units that we used in a similar
manner last winter to see whether we
could secure their availability for this
winter but it seems that might not be so
simple here's the picture last winter
when the National Grid had five coal
units on emergency standby two here at
edf's West bertinay and Nottinghamshire
one here at unipers Ratcliffe On saw
power station nearby and two at Drax in
Yorkshire between them these coal units
were warmed a number of times just in
case and actually used once during the
Cold Snap in March but this winter
things are looking much less certain
wesburton a has closed as planned it's
far too old to stay open Ratcliffe is
going to be used for routine commercial
power generation and therefore isn't
available for emergencies and now it
appears that Drax the only real
remaining option is very unlikely to be
able to help
in a statement a spokesperson told Sky
News as we announced in April we have
closed our coal units at Drax and have
started the decommissioning process
since then we have had various
discussions with government and the
National Grid electricity system
operator but we are not in negotiations
to extend their availability into the
coming winter the grid says it has
plenty of other tools at its disposal to
help balance the system it is likely to
keep using its demand flexibility scheme
which pays consumers to use less at
times of peak demand but some believe
the rush to phase out coal completely by
October next year is a mistake we've had
situations where there's been low wind
output in the summer it's not just the
case that we need these contingencies in
the winter we need all year round to
have the tools to manage different
weather patterns as the weather becomes
more important to the amount of
generation that we can produce
an example of the complexities and
challenges involved as the UK continues
its transition to clean power Hannah
Thomas Peter Sky News
the mother of Alfie Steele and her
partner will spend decades behind bars
for the killing and torture of the
nine-year-old Alfie was beaten held down
in a cold bath and suffered 50 separate
injuries Carla Scots will spend 27 years
in prison for manslaughter and child
cruelty while Dirk Howell was sentenced
to life and will serve at least 32 years
England Captain Ben Stokes says he's
confident he'll be able to bowl in the
ashes Series against Australia Stokes is
recovering from a knee injury but bold
in the final training session today all
players will wear black armbands and
hold a moment's silence at edgebeston
for the victims of the attacks in
Nottingham
yeah last three days have been really
good for my confidence I've bowled every
day so far and been able to sort of run
in with more intensity day by day so
I've got myself in a in a real good
place to be able to bowl but David
sakers obviously came in and he
mentioned something to me last week down
in Scotland saying if you're still
bowling by the fourth and fifth test
then we've done something right
The Grieving families of two people
killed when ticketless fans rushed to
get into a concert at the Brixton
Academy in South London have blamed
greed and a lack of safety measures for
their deaths Rebecca ikamelo and Gabby
Hutchinson died days after being
seriously injured in the crash last
December a criminal investigation is
still underway as Matthew Thompson
reports
this is the moment of an ordinary Night
Out turned into tragedy
fans queue to get into the Brixton O2
Academy there's a sudden surge in the
crowd
the crush left 33 year old Rebecca
icarmelo and 23 year old Gabby
Hutchinson dead and another woman
seriously injured six months on their
families are still reeling it's got two
young kids
they are missing their mom
they don't really know what that
actually happened to their mom
you know so
there is no one Justice
but to get that Justice first the
families need answers
kiss you but that's why we want everyone
to come forward that does know anything
because it could be your family next
you know we watch things on TV and you
just think that will never happen to us
and we're now sitting here in that
situation
questions have been raised about
security and ticketing procedures at the
venue on the night the police have made
it clear that they're considering
charges of corporate and criminal
negligence manslaughter
the doors of this I
cycle suspended its license the police
have called for that license to be
revoked that would spell the end of 40
Years of live music here
but in the last few months a campaign
has sprung up to save the O2 Academy
supported by Major acts like blur and
The Prodigy we have to consider how
important this iconic venue is in terms
of the UK cultural economy uh and also
over and above that the importance of
the learnings that we can take from it
so that we don't have these incidents uh
happen
lessons May one day be learned from the
tragedy that unfolded here but before
that there must be answers
Matthew Thompson Sky News
now from Hollywood to Westminster Glenda
Jackson was today remembered as a
formidable politician and one of our
greatest movie actresses over a career
spanning several decades she played
Queens Kings and a woman struggling with
dementia but excuse the trappings of
luxury and as a labor MP she was a
fierce critic of the war in Iraq and the
policies of Margaret Thatcher Skies Cody
Spencer takes a look back at her life
Oscar winner Glenda Jackson receives yet
again another award her Talent lit up
the stage and scream in the film that
won her her first Oscar Oliver Reed
famously described acting alongside
Glenda Jackson is being run over by a
truck her performances were Fearless
[Music]
just say you love me born in birkenhead
after winning a scholarship to Radha she
came to the attention of the royal
Shakespeare company and while she never
looked back she never forgot her working
class Roots the driving force having
actually gone into wanting to be an
actress was getting a job
um but to actually have a job meant that
you could eat as her contemporaries
traded off their sex appeal on stage or
screen Jackson brought a unique
intensity it was real playing the Virgin
Queen in 1971 she was by this stage a
household name
remember me Glenda but she didn't take
herself too seriously look
if you want to take your wife to the
theater please do just don't give me she
won a second Oscar starring opposite
George Siegel in romantic comedy A Touch
of Class the Stella rolls kept coming at
the height of her success having worked
consistently into her 50s came a massive
handbrake turn and she decided her
future lay on a different stage
politics elected in 1992 devoting 23
years to representing Hampstead and
Kilburn as a labor MP
outspoken on the Iraq War Universal
Credit and when Margaret Thatcher died
summing up the former prime minister's
Legacy as greed selfishness no care for
the weaker sharp elbows sharp knees
there was an edge to everything she did
um she and and once she'd sorted out
what she thought she would put her she
would land her punch whenever she wanted
to in the chamber of the House of
Commons when she retired from
Westminster in 2015 she returned to
where she'd left off at the age of 82
playing one of Shakespeare's most
challenging Parts King Lear to Five Star
reviews Elizabeth is missing I know it
winning awards for her acting as
recently as 2020 unafraid to speak her
mind with her fearless dismissal of the
pretensions of Hollywood Glenda Jackson
was a one-off a phenomenal Talent on
whichever stage she chose to Grace Katie
Spencer's Sky News
it's the remarkable life of Glenda
Jackson and that was Sky News at 10.
coming up we're going to take a first
look at tomorrow's papers in the Press
preview including this story it's on the
front of the eye their headline he lied
and lied and lied and tonight I'll be
joined by contributing editor at Navara
media Moya Lothian McLean and chief
executive at the total politics group
Mark Wallace do join us in a couple of
minutes
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
hello time for the Press preview then
it's our first look at what is on
tomorrow's front pages and having a look
at the headlines with us tonight
contributing editor at Navara media
moyolovium clay now the chief executive
at the total politics group Mark Wallace
they'll be with us from now until just
before midnight a very good evening to
both of you we'll chat in a moment after
we've had a look at those front pages
beginning with the I which leads on the
Privileges committee reports into Boris
Johnson saying he lied and lied and lied
meanwhile the Metro asks if his alleged
lies to Parliament our career ending
the Ft says he's being condemned in a
damning report
while the guardian focuses on that
90-day suspension the committee
recommended for Boris Johnson had he
still been a member of parliament here's
the daily mail it says Tory MPS and
Grassroots activists have been left
Furious by the party gate report
the telegraph also focuses on the
response of Boris Johnson's allies
response to the report saying they will
oust the MPS who vote for his censure
The Daily Express describes the
committee's findings as the most
spiteful stitch up in the history of
politics
and no holes barred from The Daily Star
which depicts Boris Johnson as Pinocchio
and don't forget you can scan that QR
code that you see on screen during the
program and you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers that while
you watch us discussing there man
tonight we're joined by Milo V McLean
and Mark Wallace great to see you both
on this uh rather warm and humid evening
and uh it's interesting looking at the
front pages because they are very split
we've got the mail saying it's
vindictive while the I says he lied and
lied and lied Mark we knew this report
would be damning but it was scathing
wasn't it
absolutely very much so I've got to say
Jonathan somehow every time we review
the papers together something massive
seems to happen you know oh to have a
quiet night of news
um yes the report was absolutely
scathing it didn't pull any punches and
a lot of the evidence that went with it
including from uh unnamed special
advisors other people around Downing
Street added yet more quite shocking
detail but frankly I don't think
tomorrow's newspapers are going to have
quite enough space to go through and
pick over all the details from it we'll
see several more days of Fallout from
the report alone clearly the MPS on that
committee I think were not um we're not
calmed in their response by the way
Boris Johnson had conducted himself with
regards to the inquiry and we're hearing
a lot of you know bile and Fury from
from the former prime minister and from
his um most enthusiastic and devoted
supporters But ultimately it comes down
when you look at a report like this in
terms of the original behavior and then
the lies to try and excuse and divert
and direct from it the only hasn't
himself to blame if you if Boris Johnson
had been whiter than white as he ought
to and you know as part of the price of
getting to run the country
um by following everything that he is he
and his own government had set out and
then if stuff had gone wrong if he put
his hands up to it he wouldn't be in
this position but he isn't ultimately a
spiteful angry tone to a report as he as
his allies are alleging doesn't change
the the material that it found yeah but
Mark he says uh it was up rather
than conspiracy doesn't he and he says
that this is all all a vendetta
well he says that it's a vendetta
there's a slight degree of um he would
say that wouldn't he to quote someone
else involved in a different Scandal
some decades ago
um but the fact is that this report
doesn't say mistakes were made you know
we've all heard a thousand one reports
from different arms of the British State
over the years says mistakes were made
lessons will be learned it says that
there were lies and that is a
fundamentally different thing that's
about uh knowing untruth not mistakes of
a mission or just overlooking things the
fact is that everyone watching this show
tonight will remember what those rules
were like we can remember their force
and then the the the vital importance of
them we can remember when they got
absurd and things like the the the the
snacks and debate over the Scotch egg
counted as a substantial meal in a
purple all that kind of stuff the is the
people around the country went through
an awful lot
um in that Dreadful period and
understandably they're Furious and they
find out people who are setting the
rules making rules were breaking rules
yeah uh Moya we're looking ahead to
Monday there's going to be a vote uh in
the house the front page of the Metro
which seems to be on a run of of good
headlines at the moment is proper
Whopper a career stopper and what's your
verdict on on this whole Affair and do
you think that Boris Johnson's political
career is over now
well I think good headlines are in the
eye of the beholder definitely Rhymes
um I don't know if Boris Wilson's career
is over you'd think that something like
this would be so big so damning that no
one can ever come back from it but if
you look at the history of British
government plenty of people have
recovered their careers in some manner
or other whether that is within
Parliament or without you look at the
chilco inquiry after that you saw that
Tony blanoster Campbell would probably
never be on Frontline politics again in
the same manner but they still have
careers Boris Johnson make over 1
million pounds last year in speaking
fees alone he might not be back in the
Commons as an MP but that doesn't mean
that he won't continue to profit from
his long 18 years within Parliament or
whether he will still be involved in
politics in some manner as a Statesman
who gives his opinions I think that we
have a very short-term memory when it
comes to disgraced politicians in this
country and Moya what about the uh the
verdict of the committee a 90-day
suspension
um if he'd still be an MP of course um
but but he resigned do you think that is
is fair some are arguing it's perhaps
overreaching
well that 90-day suspension was actually
imposed because of Boris Johnson's
premature response to the committee's
confidential letter that they sent him
last week saying look this is what we've
decided it was going to be a 20-day
suspension but because Boris Johnson
decided to jump the gun resign not take
the suspension in case it triggered a
by-election you'd have to leave in what
he saw as I guess a losing to the
committee's rulings instead he decided
to jump before he was pushed and because
of that and because of what he said in
that letter that he released when he
said he was resigning with an immediate
effect they increased the suspension to
90 days it's rather than you know
bolting
um The Barn Door after the horse has
already gone but there's clear they gave
they gave very clear articulate reasons
for why they'd increase the suspension
because of this campaign that they
called of abuse that they said Boris
Johnson had been complicit in and there
also might be a follow-up report that is
coming this was written by the
Privileges committee about that abuse
and the cam painting on the behalf of
Boris Johnson's allies that sought to
undermine The credibility of the
Privileges committees and those that sat
upon it so that the verdicts when it was
delivered on Boris Johnson would not be
taken as seriously and as we've seen
would be surrounded by this miasma of
conspiracy
okay well let's have a look at the front
page of the Daily Mail we can imagine uh
their take the headline Tory Revolt over
vindictive bid to banish Boris
um where does all this leave Mark uh the
Grassroots conservatives many of whom
are still big fans of of Boris Johnson
and and indeed the public
I think it's possible to kind of over
egg the idea of a um you know there may
well be a tour of Revolt as the male
says I'm skeptical that there'll be a
Civil War and some commentators have
been saying I think if you see in
parliamentary terms I think Boris
Johnson hasn't managed to hold together
his support base on the green benches in
the National Commons
um anywhere near as strongly as he might
have liked in the Grassroots he has a uh
from the evidence I've seen a minority
but sizeable minority of people who are
still very enthusiastic about it and who
are very annoyed about this I've got to
say touching on what Molly just said
this format of a committee investigating
a committee potentially uh disability of
other MPS deciding whether you trigger
well whether a punishment should pass a
boundary that potentially triggers a
by-election I think is a far is a less
than ideal one I think it does leave the
road open for there to be dispute and
allegations of personal bias and so on
back in the Coalition years and the
stories were elected in 2010 promising
there will be what's called a recall
power the idea that voters would get to
choose if enough voters in the
constituency in a short enough time
signed a petition or similar they'll be
able to trigger a by-election that was
watered down with the with the live Dems
and the Coalition agreement and the
conservatives agreed to water it down
and Zach ultimate actually Boris Johnson
Ally was the person proposing
full fact recall that would put this in
the hand of photos it was watered down
that produced this committee fudge and I
think we can see that it's a less than
ideal route because it crosses over
whether people are being passed as iron
or whether political or personal
dislikes coming into it that leaves it
open in this kind of arguments I'm also
quite uncomfortable with the idea the
committee should start disciplining
people who criticize the committee
um you know I think if you're going to
have a system like this you do need to
stop someone you can't have a kind of uh
approach in which you start saying you
should be punished for criticizing the
way in which the committee goes about
things
you might like its conclusions or not
but parliamentarians should be free to
decide that and voters should decide
who's this involvement yeah interesting
point um before we move on to to our
next story
um our political editor better be said
tonight that the vote on Monday will be
a litmus test really for for Boris
Johnson and his standing now would you
agree with that
I mean obviously I also I just want to
come back on the point that Mark made
well I totally agree that there's always
to be more power put within the
Grassroots rather than just amps we
should have a full functioning democracy
what's interesting about this committee
and the you know allegations that they
say were abusive towards them is that
throughout this process Boris Johnson
his allies have been claiming that this
is a kangaroo court they said this is a
Witch Hunt they've been using all this
very inflammatory language four of the
seven MPS on that committee are breast
tears it is a Tory Laden committee and
it was one that was put together when
Boris Johnson was still prime minister
he had the opportunity to whip the MPS
to make sure that Harriet Harman who has
been the focus of a lot of these attacks
and accusations of bias was not the head
of that committee that didn't happen at
the time
it's there's criticism and there's what
the allies of Boris Johnson and Boris
Johnson have been doing which is why it
has led to this uh verdict that there's
been a campaign to undermine The
credibility of this committee and I
would say that that has been accurate
what happens now and whether there
should be further action taken you know
it seems a bit ridiculous if we get to
the report on a report on a report about
who did what but there's no denying that
has there has been a concert concerted
effort to make the committee look like
it was biased in a way that it simply
wasn't
okay listen we're going to move on
because we're heading towards the break
and I want to just uh touch on the front
of the guardian and this awful story
today it's on the on the right of the
the guardian about this
um sinking of a migrant vessel Mark
feared that 500 uh are uh uh hopes fade
for 500 still feared uh Missing I mean
this is a real tragedy
absolutely a horrendous um news about
which we're still learning uh yet more
um as you say that that Guardian report
covers a gentleman who's flown to Greece
in search of his wife who he believes
was on this ship and he is left with no
news no information no cloudy and what
appears to be one of the worst Maritime
disasters of of recent years and again
it seems
um people being put in deadly power and
dying at the hands of completely
ruthless
um people smuggling girls
yeah my women and children as well
believe to be on board
yeah those reports early reports are
saying that at least a hundred children
were in the hole and what this will come
down to is we've seen time and time
again is also not just looking at the
people smuggling gangs but looking at
the authorities that were involved or
not involved in the rescue process has
already been conflicting reports about
authorities not coming to help when they
were asked and the authorities in Greece
are saying no that people refused help
what we've seen in the past with the the
disaster that happened the channel is
there is a long-term back and forth
before any families or victims or
survivors get answers about what really
happened and that's going to be an even
more torturous process for those who are
left yeah just uh desperate isn't it
okay both thank you for the moment we'll
speak again uh shortly coming up after
the break the metro and other papers
have the latest from Nottingham a huge
vigil was held this evening following
the attacks which left three people
there discussing that and more
[Music]
I me and my ex-partner were trying to
have a child
um for almost 18 months
um and then we realized that
yeah I had some fertility problems
um so she had gone first to go and get
herself checked and then I followed
suits and then it came out that I was
one of the problem when you were young
yes I started we started when I was 31
yeah I'm now 33. I had something called
undescended testicles which I felt like
as if it was a a problem and that was
that when I was in it that was at the
age of 11.
um and then we moved on from there and
then we just went for this rigorous and
series of tests
um trying to get to the end conclusion
as to why I haven't got any sperm Indian
I did get sperm they were able to
retrieve sperm but they were just
looking as to
you know why it never happened for me
naturally
um so yeah it was very very challenging
yeah and what impact did it have on you
mentally oh it was um extreme extremely
difficult um for me to kind of
process as to why I don't have any sperm
and you know trying to navigate myself
in this journey of yeah wanting to have
a baby with my partner and you know make
things will challenge you for our
relationship and yes it was but it was
tough but I always I always said to
myself that
um even if it doesn't happen for me
there's a purpose for my life for me to
kind of spread awareness around this
important subject yeah so in about a
third of cases uh where couples are
struggling to concede there is a male
Factor sometimes it could be quite
Extreme as we just heard Jonathan where
there's no sperm being produced but it's
very important that at an early stage of
failing to conceive that that the man
also has a sperm test to to try and
understand is there an issue there and
if there is a problem with his sperm
then there are further tests that can be
done to try and understand why there's a
problem generally being healthier this
is true for men and women willing will
improve fertility so trying to normalize
uh your weight obviously there's
increasing levels of obesity so trying
to normalize weight is important uh
moderate amounts of alcohol and caffeine
smoking is bad for sperm and fertility
um generally be healthy good healthy
diet
um but I think to be fair for most
people for most men who have problems
with their sperm it's not something that
they can just fix by improving their own
life style I think that it does need
investigating and then to see whether
there's any medical treatment possible
for them
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
hello welcome back Moya and Mark are
still with us part two of The Press
preview Moya let's talk about events in
Nottingham because yet again today close
family members of those who died gave
remarkable speeches their bravery in
standing up and addressing the crowds
was incredible and actually also really
unusual isn't it to see relatives going
through this sort of trauma prepared to
do something like this
I would say in more recent years I've
remembered there have been a number of
families who've made a point of standing
up and saying like um Grace O'Malley
Kumar's mother did please don't have any
Hate in Your Hearts which was a really
key emotive line from this I remember
when the London Bridge attacks occurred
then we saw the family of the young man
that was killed Jack they stood up and
said something very very similar and put
out public statements and I think it is
a reflection of the current political
climate we live in and perhaps the speed
at which information is circulated
across social media you get all these
tidbits about the person who is alleged
to have attacked these young people and
Ian Coates who was also killed in
Nottingham and you get a lot of
speculation immediately
none of this is helpful for families who
are grieving but also the pursuit of
justice for their lost ones and we have
seen it more frequently I was saying in
recent years that families have come out
and said please don't jump to
conclusions please don't say this please
don't say that please don't have hate
that's not what our lost loved ones
believed in and they made some
absolutely devastating speeches the you
know Barnaby Weber's mother talking
about the fact that he didn't she didn't
know what he was doing doing history
perhaps because he wanted to be a pilot
and perhaps it was the wanted to fly
Spitfires it's those small little
details that just really remind you of
what is gone it's tragic on every level
yeah Mark two youngsters uh clearly
loving life and a school caretaker who
was described today as selfless
yes two people at the very start of
their lives their adventures in the
world and uh one gentleman who so many
tributes from the community that he was
part of as to how much he had dedicated
his life to helping people I'm going to
say I'm in awe of families who at this
moment of dreadful trauma can have the
bravery and strength to speak out uh
publicly in the way they did I go forbid
I you know I I now that I would have the
strength to be able to do that in their
second sense I do hope that we don't
come to expect this as being a kind of
thing which should should automatically
expect to people these evidently are
families who've made incredibly Brave
decision that have taken this moment to
give a gift of their advice and their
message to their Community which I think
is hugely admirable yeah it really is
um and let's finish with the front of
the daily telegraphs uh more a fabulous
picture there of Glenda Jackson Oscar
and the actress of course former labor
MP
um and it's been really interesting
hearing today about her life and really
being reminded of of of two fantastic
careers
yeah God wasn't she a Powerhouse she won
two Academy Awards didn't one didn't
bother going and picking up either of
them they ended up as bookends in her
mother's house she said and she's had 23
years as a labor MP after she'd won an
Oscar Tony Emmy and she was one of the
most articulate performers that we had
in the House of Commons and it really
shows in the tributes you have papers
like the Telegraph and the Daily Mail
who would you know you think normally
would be opposed to someone like Glenda
Jackson who was a committed socialist
but no they are staying there and
they're paying tribute I think that
shows the absolute command and Legacy
that she has and the respect that she
garnered for her long and illustrious
career fighting for people's rights yeah
and Mark when we hear about uh MP's egos
as we do quite a lot she is one who
appeared not to have an ego she didn't
even bother going to pick up her two
Oscars
and dare I say you even hear the actors
often have egos as well but so so she
managed the double whammy of defining
expectations on on that front but it's
also it's also as a reminder about how
important it is that we have people from
which are people in in Parliament both
hands of parliament from a really wide
range of perspectives and expertise ins
you know it's totally valid for there to
be young MPS um as well as MPS who who
are late in their lives I'm not someone
who signs up so you must have done a
certain amount of Decades of something
else but it's great to have Parliament
leavened and improved by such a range of
of different backgrounds and hers was
one of the most unique and she was the
star of more commonwise which we
shouldn't forget no and we've been great
watching that clip again today hasn't it
uh Mark Moya thank you very much
malcolmo will be staying with us for the
next hour to discuss tonight's news and
tomorrow's headlines right now let's
take a look at the weather